[Musique]
et
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau avait y est je me trouve
actuellement au trianon palace à
versailles un hôtel cinq étoiles
emblématique qui a été créée en 1910 et
à mes côtés c'était pagny et rambo
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
je le rappelle vous êtes la directrice
de l'établissement versailles et et ce
depuis le mois de janvier 2022
exactement mais voilà donc vous avez
pris vos fonctions récemment et vous
êtes la première femme à la tête du
trianon palace est ce que c'est une
fierté déjà bien sûr évidemment parce
que c'est comme vous l'avez dit un hôtel
emblématique un sit-in hôtel
personnellement pour laquelle je suis
très attaché ça fait quelques années que
je travaille avec liedson et j'ai vu un
petit peu cette source elle dans le
contexte de mon travail d'avants et
c'était toujours l'hôtel qui m'a
passionné donc évidemment très fier mais
voilà fier non pas juste d'être d'être
la première femme depuis 1910 parce que
nos directs en avant ils ont fait un
merveilleux travail
et je pense que c'est pas le fait d'être
normaux d'être une femme mais voilà tu
être impliqués et de voile a aimé sa
belle bâtiment et donc plus globalement
qu'est ce que ça représente pour vous ce
poste est finalement la ville de
versailles en général
à ce poste beaucoup de potentiel parce
que c'est un hôtel qui a oui que je
trouve a énormément potentiel bas
par rapport à sa localisation
donc on crée effectivement dont
versailles jeu ça côté du château mais
aussi ben voilà à cause de cette cet art
de vivre ses jardins le spa guerlain
notre restaurant gastronomique
voilà je pense qu'il a énormément
potentiel et
et voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et vous avez cité tout ce potentiel est
ce que finalement pour vous le tri en
place représente bien la culture à la
française ben évidemment l'art de vivre
la couture à la france est et puis on
est à versailles donc c'est quoi votre
pièce où votre endroit préféré au
trianon ah ah je dois dire que ça doit
être la suite sera-ce le switch arras
parce qu'elle est elle surplombe un peu
versailles et là vous avez vu absolument
magnifique du château donc ça c'est
vraiment moi préférerait donc un lieu un
peu privilégiés
stéphanie en gros vous êtes originaire
donc du royaume uni est-ce que vous
pouvez nous parler un peu de votre
parcours avant justement d'être ici oui
effectivement donc je suis anglais 500
en jeu
mon amour un peu pour l'autre sellerie
ça vient de mon oncle qui était
propriétaire de deux hôtels dans le nord
de l'angleterre et il ya g voilà j'ai
commencé mon travail dans l'hôtellerie
en angleterre dans différentes fonctions
plus tôt dans la partie opérationnelle
j'ai rencontré longuement mari qui est
français après et on arrive en france
c'était plutôt dans la partie
commerciale marketing pour lesquels j'ai
passé des années donc avec le groupe
starwood avec
le groupe in the continental et
finalement donc le groupe victimes pour
lesquelles ça fait maintenant saisons
que je suis dans ce groupe là il ya de
beaux trophées storia p700 sais pas mais
ou encore pastore on sait pas toujours
et la partie luxe en fait dans le groupe
it est donc selon vous qu'est-ce qui a
fait que vous en êtes arrivé là
aujourd'hui un ca doit être beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup de travail
mais notre industrie a fait en sorte
qu'on est dans 44 donc on s est vrai
très très impliqué dans ce qu'on fait et
voilà donc les hommes que tu n'étais
aussi eu la chance on va revenir à vous
à vos fonctions actuelles c'est quoi
finalement le rôle de la directrice du
trianon palace au quotidien
cette chose que je dirais c'est vraiment
notre sens du détail est aussi c'est
d'avoir cette vision qui est plus global
plus long terme un c'est de se mettre
dans voilà dans les chaussures du client
pour anticiper ses besoins pour
pour vraiment oui anticiper tous ces à
ses désirs essayer également 2
voilà de former nos équipes et de faire
ensemble et sont attentifs à la demande
de nos clients leur a dit vous avez pris
vos fonctions en janvier 2022 donc c'est
tout récent 1 finalement comment ça se
passe jusqu'à maintenant là on en avril
c'est super excitant
j'ai été très bien accueilli par par les
équipes
c'était quand même à la sortie d'une
période un peu compliquée avec le comité
pour les clients et pour le personnel
mais là je sens qu'il ya vraiment
beaucoup de vie beaucoup détermination
par rapport à nos équipes de faire en
sorte qu'on retrouve en fait nos marques
et aussi nos clients ils ont envie de
venir sont vides de passer d'autres
entraîneurs relations ça c'est très
satisfaisant donc positif jusqu'à
montreuil positif vous avez un métier
qui est prenant et on l'a dit tout à
l'heure faut tout gérer comment vous
arrivez à concilier finalement une vie
comme ça à 200 à l'heure et une vie
privée euh je pense que ça revient sur
ce qu'en disait tout à l'heure c'est de
l'énergie j'en ai j'en ai beaucoup et il
ya et aussi un petit peu de faire la
part des choses donc
voilà donc j'y arrive avoir une vie
familiale
envie de travail qui sont tous les deux
voilà plan est passionnant il ya et
voilà un roman va pas avec eux sont
d'autres
pour l'heure est ce que vous avez à des
projets des souhaits à long terme pour
l'hôtel justement sommes énormément jeu
je pense que cet outil l on disait que
c'est un hôtel qui était construit en
1910 donc pour moi 1910-1920 c'était
vraiment l'hôtel à l'époque qui
accueillit les parisiens il y avait les
serveurs narcy avec wallace côté très
glamour donc
j'aimerais bien ont coûté plus de
l'amour pour revenir un peu sur
voilà sur cette retraite très
prestigieux d'avant
je pense qu'on y est on y est presque
c'est vraiment la maison des parisiens
cette sauce elle
évidemment nous avons clientèle
internationale qui est importante mais
voilà c'est la maison dé versailles et
même la maison des parisiens ailleurs et
voilà donc il faut appuyer là-dessus
[Musique]
et à court terme du coup quels sont vos
objectifs j'imagine que vous êtes déjà
en train de préparer la haute saison oui
c'est une grande saison pour nous vous
voyez donc là on est déjà dehors sur
notre terrasse on fait le trianon palace
doubler de taille en été parce que nous
avons énormément d'espacé des jardins et
des terrasses ont fait beaucoup de pique
nique de bavay qe2 voilà donc c'est
vraiment beaucoup d'activités pour nous
le grand don de jeu évidemment c'est
qu'un autre notre équipe grandit sur sur
la période
donc nous avons
voilà un équipe plus large et nous
sommes actuellement en train de recruter
et former nos équipes pour les saisons
donc là le recrutement est encore ouvert
si jamais pour versailles bien sûr oui
oui pas encore que pas encore clôturée
pour les saisons d'accord très bien et
on peut candidater par exemple en allant
sur le site tout en appelant directement
oui tout à fait appel directement
l'hôtel où vous pouvez aller également
sur des sites vous avez les coordonnées
de notre direct rester ressources
humaines donc à recrutement à venir pour
la haute saison et puis bien sûr une
évolution peut-être dans les mois ou les
années à venir merci beaucoup stéphanie
rambo d'avoir été avec nous et je le
rappelle vous êtes la directrice
générale du waldorf astoria versailles
et trianon palace et c'est la fin de ce
fait greg p merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous attribuer de sûreté les 78
[Musique]